notre panel d'experts fédéraux et là
jean pierre blackburn à saguenay yvon
godin a battu celle à copse à ottawa
pierre fakate à montréal bon sens là
vous ont pas touché par cette comment
dire cette crise des migrants mais
évidemment la compagnie grands
maintenant on a tous la même photo en
tête on a tous la même image c'est un
petit garçon il a trois ans s'appelle
allen son père l'a enterré aujourd'hui
il a été retrouvé sur une plage hier
stephen harper a commenté cela en
parlant de plusieurs axes trois grands
axes pour voir la crise des migrants
il ya des gens qui ont eu de fortes
réactions qui to get me suis rarement
manqué un peu de sensibilité aujourd'hui
le corriger son message on va voir
comment il présentait les chaussettes et
prévisions je n'ai pas dit qu'il y à un
opposition entre un politique de
réfugiés est un politique des militaires
au contraire j'ai dit qu'on doit faire
les deux et pour l'augmentation du
nombre de réfugiés syriens
j'ai déjà annoncé ça avant cet incident
dont cette campagne électorale j'ai déjà
annoncé notre intention d'augmenter le
nombre de réfugiés syriens et
d'améliorer le processus se blackburn
seven rappeur avait pas le choix de
modifier un peu son message aujourd'hui
il met un petit peu de cas peut-être à
l'intérieur mais moi aussi j'ai trouvé
ça très intéressant sans précision je
pense que ça va échapper à tout le monde
effectivement le premier ministre s'est
engagé à ce qu' il ya dix mille nouveaux
réfugiés additionnel en provenance de la
syrie en partir d'après l'élection a au
total on a environ 20 22 mille réfugiés
aux migrants de la syrie qui peuvent
entrer au canada
alors pour moi cette précision elle
était très important d comment ça se
fait que ça nous a échappé rappelez vous
l'histoire d'ofi en tout le monde est à
tellement là dessus les nouvelles
étaient constamment sur son père m'a
donné on oublie cette dimension là
maintenant aussi il ya personne je pense
au canada même dans le monde entier
qu'on a vu le petit est rien
elad morts comme ça et là oui alors ça
nous c'est c'est triste ça nous touche
et veut pas on dit bon quoi faire par
rapport à ce drame là qui se passe c'est
suffisant parce que c'est ça la question
je vais demander justement à vous et à
votre compagne et vos compagnons ici
qu'on voit dans l'écran est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est suffisant parce que
les chefs des autres partis eux ont
l'air de vouloir aller beaucoup plus
loin que simplement dire on va en
accueillir on veut remettre tout ça en
marche ou maintenir notre engagement une
fois les élections passées madame coop
mais je pense que d'abord c'est une
crise qui a commencé il ya trois ans
passés et depuis le tout début il ya
déjà annoncé 23 mille personnes mais il
ya moins de 2500 qui sont venus j'ai
entendu le ministre de l'immigration du
québec aujourd'hui qui a dit que par
rapport au gouvernement par les citoyens
privés comme la tante du petit arn
le gouvernement fédéral a accepté huit
réfugiés au québec
8 alors c'est pas une question de parler
des caisses qui nous allons faire dans
le futur et le 10000 dans dont jean
pierre a parlé tantôt il a précisé que
ça doit être des gens des milieux
minoritaires soit des chrétiens ou bien
des musulmans qui vivent en situation
minoritaire ailleurs il ya tellement
qu'ils se sauvent mais le fait de créer
une nouvelle processus ça prend plus de
temps et ils ont créé leurs propres
problèmes
on va vous avez entendu monsieur coderre
1 le maire de montréal l'enquêté sur nos
zones ya quelques minutes à peine
lui il lance vraiment un cri et il est
appuyé là dessus par cinquantenaire
c'est dingue ou talons du pays ici qui
disent écoutez est-ce qu'on peut arrêter
de s'en faire jouer avec les chiffres
les procédures et tout le tralala
est-ce qu'on peut aller de l'avant parce
qu'il faut vraiment agir on est dans un
mode urgence il appuyait sur le mont
urgence monsieur codex en pensez quoi
regardez écoutez je veux dire français
c'est regrettable que ce qui arrive et
puis le tlm quant à lui si les plages
sûr c'est une personne qu'on a vu ses
plages en petit jeu s'imaginer ckoi
l'horreur qui a présentement dans ces
réfugiés l'eau puis en étions obligés
d'attendre on est un élection le 19
octobre
moi je pense que tout le monde est
d'accord pour agir immédiatement
ce sont les politiques de côté de ça les
partis politiques de côté le
gouvernement a une responsabilité
fondamentale qui jeu s'entend dire que
on l'a manqué dans le temps de
l'histoire de dauphy là n'en faut agir
maintenant
photo yan a réagi avant mais maintenant
c'est le temps d'agir
c'est important le canado faut que
devient le canada qu'on était un canada
de kéké qui est ouvert
un canadair qui est un coeur ce soit
faux demanderez au reste du monde
puis il faut que tu appelles lure a
aussi bien comme deux canadairs qui
regardent avec le nul et des
recommandations qui a été fait et c'est
comme deux thermos manquèrent le dj pour
un exemple thymine vrai que ça se fait
tout de suite ça et en plus eu copie
privée les gens qui veut recevoir des
réfugiés qui veut les raids et par année
c'est laisser les rentrées je veux dire
on peut pas accepter comme humain faut
regarder le côté humanitaire non c'est
bien beau la politique des élections
faut garder le côté humanitaire français
pire depuis que depuis la deuxième
guerre mondiale qui est en train se
passait là il faut concerne côté humain
puis en mai a vraiment en action
immédiatement mais on attendait monsieur
rappeur par contre reprocher ses
adversaires aujourd'hui de ne pas
vouloir maintenir le canada dans cette
coalition militaire pour attaquer le
problème à sa source
parce qu'à la source on sait il ya
d'abord une crise en syrie avec deux
grands pôles ici d'un côté bachar al
assad en dans ce mouvement
révolutionnaire là qui traîne depuis
et de l'autre côté il ya les avancées du
groupe armé état islamique
monsieur paquette du bloc ou et je pense
que personne qui a opposé l'action
militaire ou en fait
il ya des gens qui sont en désaccord
parce que monsieur trudeau a dit que se
retirait je pense que les intérêts des
aussi dans le code bloc québécois mais
se dissipe au dit qu'on n'avait pas de
problème avec l'intervention dans la
coalition contre l'état islamique mais
il faut faire quelque chose pour les
réfugiés le petit garçon serait mort
même si on mettait plus d'avions dans
l'émission de de combat alors c'est un
problème qui est qui est complémentaire
et et auquel il faut immédiatement
apporter des solutions et il faut
reconnaître que depuis que les
conservateurs sont au pouvoir
les mesures pour recevoir des réfugiés
ont été durcies alors ça c'est pas une
réalité que je dénonce tous les
spécialistes aujourd'hui qui s'occupe de
ces questions là on constater qu'au fil
des presque neuf ans de pouvoir du parti
conservateur on a resserré la vis je
vous donne un petit exemple le venice
des migrations monsieur alexander sans
vote souhaitant tahoua pour voir ces
dossiers avaient été déposés
effectivement comme ç'avait été
mentionné il n'y a pas eu d'aussi oui
parce que c'était le frère du père du
petit garçon qui était parrainée par sa
tante et parce que les règles
interdisent d'avoir deux parrainage en
même temps donc cette dame qui vit en
colombie britannique en fait un choix
malheureux
on le sait maintenant mais c'est les
règles qu'il faut changer
j'ai trouvé que monsieur encore a manqué
beaucoup de compassion alors que tous
les autres chefs y compris monsieur
trudeau aussi bien monsieur mulcair où
monsieur ducept ont voulu élever le
débat pour s'assurer qu'il ya une
solution rapide pour ces réfugiés
l'autre nom et malheureusement j'ai pas
eu suis pas senti cette compassion la
part de monsieur harper monsieur
alexander et ça je trouve ça extrêmement
dommage de se blesser
vous évoquiez tantôt d'entrée de jeu
justement la crise deux filles là où
vous avez dit tous les médias l'avez
leur focus là dessus là maintenant c'est
plus la crise de fille l'économie
écouter on a passé pratiquement de sulo
dans le temps d'un clin d'oeil avec
cette histoire de récession pratiquement
déjà terminé maintenant
mais cette histoire leur risque de
coller actuellement acheté vient de
refermer ce paquet le disait cette
impression finalement de manque de
sensibilité
et ou de manque de compassion et cette
impression qu'il donne de ne pas
comprendre que beaucoup de canadiens
les maires en fait qu'en fait les
sorties l'ont démontré aujourd'hui
veulent d'une part aider mais veulent
aussi une vitesse grand v qu'on accélère
le processus pour recueillir ici des
migrants est-ce que ça mais pas encore
une fois votre parti le parti
conservateur dans l'embarras alors comme
comme vous me dire on sait qu'on a
environ 20000 syrien qu'on peut
accueillir au canada en vertu de
nouvelles propositions du premier
ministre qui a mis dans sa campagne
électorale
deuxièmement les provinces aujourd'hui
et certaines villes en disant on y prend
l'accueillir ça vient encore à aider cet
aspect là et le poids ministre s'est
aussi engagé à améliorer le processus
alors les conditions pour faire en sorte
d'être plus efficaces sont maintenant
réunies il faut laisser un peu le temps
alors que tous au plus sait-on que
justement vocation
le pet a noté m le problème c'est qu'il
n'y a pas le temps je me souviens de
rauzan 19
je faisais partie d'un groupe qui
parrainait une famille de viêt nam et le
gouvernement dans le temps un
gouvernement conservateur a fait appel à
tout le monde alors nous on accepter un
créé un groupe en effet venir une
famille aimante 1 et ça a pris à peu
près six mois et le six mois c'est parce
qu il avait un problème de turbo clause
dans les camps maintenant on parle de 2
ans minimum et et même ce qu'est ce qui
était promis jusqu'à date le grenoble le
moment actuel n'a accueilli nac et que
205 et 2500 personnes alors que
l'allemagne
ces huit cent mille cent mille oui mais
alors comment fait on fait très peu par
rapport à notre capacité et le problème
même avec ce que nous mettons de l'avant
dans sa grande trop de temps les gens
sont découragés c'est pour ça que le
petit lob de lily allen s'est retrouvé
dans une situation périlleuse qui a
chiffré ses victoires
c'est comme si on va attendre que
l'élection est finie que le gouvernement
bouge et maintenant toutes les parties
sont d'accord non je veux dire nous
aurait pas de critiques là dessus c'est
qu'on va rouvrir les pas et surtout bien
tally mer les grands merde des maires
des grandes villes
du pays vit une zone dans les travailler
fort puis là on va attendre sa garde
bien là les gens commencent à s'aligner
n'en fort et on lier du laury's une
question oui mais juste un humanitaire
d'urgence le gouvernement est en place
le pendant les élections
monsieur harper et demeure le premier
ministre relaxé en 2006 alexander
demeure le ministre des migrations
ils doivent immédiatement dire aux
fonctionnaires ce qu'ils entendent
vouloir voir dans les modifications
on n'a pas besoin d'attendre après des
élections pour ça de toute façon peu
importe d'où une impression qui va
gagner l'élection le gouvernement qui va
suivre devra bouger mais le gouvernement
actuel doit bouger et monsieur harper
nous a annoncé qu'il avait annoncé des
modifications illinois qui doit nous
dire dans quel sens la vue alors
maintenant mais retournons monsieur
blackburn ici on a vu donc monsieur
europe 1 transformer un peu son message
y ajouter dix ont un niveau de
sensibilité aujourd'hui est-ce que sous
la pression et là on entend des visions
communes avec vos adversaires ici est-ce
que ça va mettre une pression telle qui
va faire en sorte me son rapport
reproche choix finalement de peut-être
franchir le pas qu'ils n'osaient pas
franchir aujourd'hui c'est à dire
justement accéléré d'une part le
processus et augmenter le nombre de
migrants qu'ils seraient reçus ici au
canada
au niveau du nombre je pense que on
s'entend on est autour de 20 milles qui
peuvent entrer présentement avec les
nouvelles données que nous avons
ceci dit ce qu'il faut faire maintenant
c'est améliorer le processus et le
premier ministre s'est engagé à le faire
alors je pense que c'est important de
minutes ces nations ils pensaient les
deux sens depuis trois ans un pour le
moment accepté - des disposant de
castres et j'ai promis depuis trois
idées et je peux si je peux ajouter
quelque chose aussi c'est que on parle
de ceux schaeffler pour 2017 alors que
l'on devrait au cours des six prochains
mois
avoir une entrée massive de réfugiés pas
de sens car de cette opération là alors
il faut vraiment la queue
le gouvernement donne des messages aux
fonctionnaires de modifier le processus
pour que rapidement on peut se gérer
j'aimerais ajouter pts c'est pas le
problème de fonctionnaires les fox c'est
le gouvernement qui a changé les règles
de jeu par gouvernement s'étaient tous
les réfugiés
mais nos zélés belgique métier ou de
religion minoritaire c'était écrit dans
la nouvelle loi de monsieur harper ce
sac et a mis le bouton dans les roues
parce que ça prend plus de temps
d'identifier des réfugiés chrétiens ou
aux minorités religieux que de laisser
la porte ouverte à tous ceux qui sont
dans le besoin qui motive qui demande un
fonctionnaire de modifier les règles
dans ce sens là il n'y a pas besoin
d'attendre
on va retourner chez moi confié
j'aimerais comprendre à monsieur
blackburn une dernière fois ici parce
que le temps file très très vite sur ce
thème là vous comprendrez
on voit les pays d'europe justement qui
mène aussi le genre de débat qu'on est
en train de mener ici on sent qu'il ya
des résistances la hongrie en est un
parfait exemple
mais un des pays qui avaient beaucoup de
réserve vient de changer d'idée c'est la
grande bretagne qui a annoncé lequel
elle accueillir des milliers de réfugiés
syriens supplémentaires sont une annonce
qui a été faite par monsieur cameron est
ce que monsieur blague oniris pas
justement d'avoir ces modèles là ces
exemples qu'on voit autour autour de
nous et là qu'on parle de david cameron
on parle de gens qui sont liées
justement dans la coalition militaire
alors c'était une pression de l'antenne
d'un pays mis une pression de l'externe
de l'image si du canada est-ce que ça
s'agite pas justement à la pression sur
ne sera pas le canada c'est un des pays
très accueillant sur dix réfugiés dans
le monde le canada était alors on est on
est déjà prêt on est des choses je pense
généreux en terme d'accueil en cours ni
13 ou 20 nouveaux clients
un sur dix parmi 195 pays sur la planète
ceci dit en même temps les pays en
europe ont de la misère eux mêmes à 100
ans
alors nous on à l'espace on est capable
d'en accueillir on parle d'une vingtaine
de milles qu'on peut accueillir
maintenant ce qui nous reste à faire
c'est d'améliorer le processus pour
tenter de l'accélérer une porte minutes
c'est un gage à la fois une question par
oui ou par non parce que le temps est
terminé maintenant je vais y aller je
faire le tour là de chacun d'entre vous
les avez vous l'impression que la photo
de la petit à l'inde c'est la photo qui
viennent donner
gros virage à cette campagne électorale
monsieur blackburn oui ou non
pour moi ça va être la photo primée de
l'année parce que c'est incroyable
comment elle touche tout le monde du
saut nous laisse madame cops oui ou non
est ce que c'est la photo qui marque un
virage absolument savez ça donne le ca
donne le coeur au problème pas seulement
les chiffres oui monsieur gaudin oui ou
non c'est la photo qui change qui fait
le virage dans cette campagne
oui mais pour moi il faut penser aux
autres qui en a rien qui est en train de
subir la même chose
oui monsieur paquet je pense que non
seulement ça change la campagne
électorale ici au canada mais ça change
toute la dynamique au plan européen et
on a on l'a vu avec l'entente entre
monsieur hollande et la chancelière
allemande qui a forcé justement la
grande beauté a changé sa position
alors monsieur harper est très isolé la
au plan international et yoland encore
19 octobre de changer son fusil d épaule
manifestement c'est vraiment le sujet
qu'on a retenu sept semaines et dont
tout le monde parle aujourd'hui enfin
heureusement mais voilà merci à vous
tous avoir été avec nous la chaîne au
revoir merci